et nous marquons une pause dans cette
rétrospective de la semaine pour
accueillir sur ce plateau sylvie léonard
bonjour vous êtes la directrice
d'yveline tourisme avec vous quelques
idées sorties pour le week end et même
pour les prochains jours et comme le
froid plutôt bien installé on l'espère
ce sont quelques idées pour se
réchauffer oui et ça tombe bien puisque
la ferme se met au chaud et la ferme se
met au chaud effectivement ça se passe à
la bergerie nationale et c'est
l'opportunité pour les plus jeunes de
participer à des ateliers de cuisine et
donc de faire un goûter avec tous les
types d'aliments qui existent par
exemple on pourra faire une pomme au
four au petit beurre ou puis les olé
également donc on mange bien et on est
au chaud à la ferme de la bergerie
nationale et de rambouillet à versailles
là aussi quelques ateliers à suivre
heure du conte et décoration tout voilà
alors l'heure du conte l'heure des
comptes c'est adam 1 dans un endroit qui
est une bibliothèque en fête et qui
s'appelle l'heure des mamans et ce sont
des contes ont mis en musique qu'on va
qu'on va proposer aux enfants donc
qu'ils vont avoir madame opéra qui va
leur raconter des histoires avec de la
musique
suivant suivant les saisons va pouvoir
découvrir vivaldi ou d'autres et les
enfants devront reconnaître s'il s'agit
d'une époque plutôt estival ou plutôt
hivernale et puis d'autre part toujours
à versailles on peut aller au musée
lambinet qu'il avoue preuve a proposé
des ateliers de décoration aux enfants
et ses ateliers de décoration ce sera
l'opportunité pour les enfants de
décorer comme on décorait les salons les
chambres xviiie siècle en choisissant
des jolis tissus et puis on aura des
détails de boiseries également et puis
il y aura aussi des comptes que l'on
pourra écouter au musée lambinet et les
enfants pourront même faire voguer
leur imagination en prenant des pastels
un petit carnet et puis faire des
dessins pour écouter après avoir écouté
les contes en décoration type xviiie
siècle ça va changer des posters
habituelle dans les chambres pour ses
abdos qu'ils ont participé autre atelier
qui va ravir aussi parents et enfants
celui proposé par l'osmothèque de
versailles des multiples senteurs à
découvrir et à redécouvrir des senteurs
oublier parfois oui alors l'osmothèque à
versailles c'est le premier
conservatoire historique des parfums
alors là il ya des ateliers qui existe
pour les enfants qui s'appelle leptine
et on va découvrir les différentes
familles de parfums à travers des
départs fin qui sont des grands crus
entre guillemets qui ont été
commercialisés à une époque qui ne le
sont plus et les enfants vont pouvoir
découvrir différentes familles qui
existent ça ça sera le 23 février et les
parents peuvent faire la même chose le
16 février en découvrant aussi les
familles de parfum et puisse entraîner
au niveau de l'odorat pour voir
reconnaître tout ça on avait parlé déjà
sur cette antenne la cuisine c'est
finalement assez facile à condition
d'avoir les bons conseils et notamment
ceux de sylvie gameplay voilà alors la
cuisine c'est facile et ça c'est à la
ferme du buisson à plaisir et les les
parents pourront s'initier à la cuisine
mais aussi les enfants qui l'avons
pouvoir avec toutes les familles
d'aliments et des produits frais
pourront ils pourront jouer à c'est moi
le chef et faire la cuisine pour tout un
repas ou alors j'aime les gâteaux ils
pourront fabriquer là toutes sortes de
gâteaux comme des meringues des cupcakes
ou des madeleines encore et tout ça va
être donc sylvie qui aime plaire elle
était sur ce plateau et on l'avait vu
avec elle c'est plus qu'une passion se
partagent pour la cuisine après cette
série d'ateliers nous allons à présent
nous intéresser aux spectacles qui sont
proposés dans le département des
yvelines tout d'abord l'incontournable
maintenant festival antigel voilà qui va
effectivement avoir lieu jusqu'au 1er
mars et là c'est une trentaine de
spectacles sur le thème de lui pour et
du rire qui vont avoir lieu alors ça
sera des one man show ça sera du théâtre
ça sera différent spectacle de cirque
également et puis de l'humour de
l'humour en musique aussi
françois xavier demaison sophie forte et
donc qu'ils vont nous produire
différents spectacles
et puis ce sera l'occasion aussi de
revoir
le site des mureaux les 23 et 24 février
prochain qui fête ses 12 ans et là tout
un tas d'artistes acrobates jongleurs et
autres nous ravir ont comme d'habitude
le festival antigel notamment avec
françois xavier demaison il se produira
le 16 février samedi 20h45 à
mantes-la-ville voici un extrait de son
spectacle pour vous faire patienter
demaison s'évade
en réécoute françois javier bienvenue au
gymnase patrick juvet
tu es tu auras un partenaire tu as
raison la boxe est un sport de gentlemen
en fait y'a pas relève au sein là bas
las le sartre l'a bien tu vas voir une
fête c'est un gros bébé
un mètre 95 130 kg cas du muscle
une fois est ce son prénom
et ne porte bien sa dernière avec 10 mai
la tenue cette semaine j'aime débauche
enchaînement uppercut crochet du droit
quand on lui a retiré ses pansements aux
hommes on aurait dit jeanne moreau
voilà là on aurait pu faire une queue de
cheval avec ses jours
quand il est entré chez lui sans fin
montre guère plus la fois hier elle
avait pris pour un sharpei
1 puis surtout il a été obligé de
refaire tous ses papiers
les photos correspondait plus
j'ai quand même temps le mec sur niveau
débutant un chaînon sainvet hip hop
demaison s'évade françois xavier
demaison qui sera donc dans le cadre du
festival antigel dans le département des
yvelines le 16 février samedi 20h45 à
mantes-la-ville le 7-8 week-end toujours
avec ses différents conseils ses idées
de sorties avec la directrice des
yvelines tourisme et deux rendez-vous
maintenant du cinéma et puis un très
beau spectacle équestre également voilà
alors c'est la voie de l'écuyer les
matinales des écuyers puisque c'est
l'opus 2013 bartabas qui est venu
s'installer à versailles depuis quelques
années fait maintenant ses 10 ans à
versailles et donc il ya deux types de
spectacles que l'on peut découvrir donc
la voie de l'écuyer qui est un spectacle
où on allie
gelé tous les jeux équestres et le
dressage m'a aussi à la chanson allez ce
crime et puis hop you do qui est un art
martial qui est fait à base de bâton
donc tout ça est un merveilleux
spectacle
que l'on peut découvrir l'après-midi et
le matin ce sont les matinales des
écuyers là c'est plutôt un spectacle de
dressage où on assiste au dressage des
merveilleux chevaux lusitaniens de
bartabas et puis après le dressage on
pourra aller suivre les chevaux dans les
écuries que l'on pourra parcourir et
poser des questions et découvrir dans
l'eure dans leur box chacun à leur tour
et donc du cinéma à présent plutôt du
court métrage du long métrage voilà du
court métrage qui est à jouy en josas ça
s'appelle l'ombre d'un court et c'est du
23 au du 22 cardon au 24 février
et donc il y aura une quarantaine de
courts métrages il faudra à sélectionner
effectivement les meilleurs trois grands
professionnels sont là pour ça il faut
quand même imaginer que il ya eu des
oscars des césar qui ont été révélés par
ce festival du court métrage donc c'est
extrêmement intéressant etc
des gens qui sont extrêmement
prometteurs qui s'y trouvent et puis il
y aura des spécifiques des activités
spécifiques pour les enfants puisqu'il y
aura des spectacles contes ou quiz
spécifiquement réservée aux enfants à
cette occasion et puis mercredi aux
alentours de 18h30 en direct la page
culture sera dédiée au cinéma justement
au 7e art avec le court métrage et le
long métrage à l'honneur ce sera à
suivre donc cette semaine mercredi pour
conclure un dernier rendez vous c'est à
saint quentin en yvelines à guyancourt
et c'est la ferme du bel ébat à deux
voix alors qu'est ce que c'est ça la
ferme du bel ébat est en fait une ferme
du xviie qui au moment de la révolution
a été racheté pour motif d'utilisation
par les révolutionnaires et puis ensuite
c'est devenu une salle de spectacle et
donc on va découvrir à la fois le côté
technique de cette salle de spectacle ce
sera le 23 février prochain mais aussi
toute son histoire mais pourquoi voilà
les deux voies une historique et une
plutôt techniques dont ce sera très
intéressant de pouvoir découvrir tout ça
on aime bien savoir le
le background et les
les coulisses de tous ces spectacles et
je rappelle si vous n'avez pas eu le
temps de tout noter toutes ces idées ces
rendez vous à noter vous pouvez revoir
cette séquence sur notre site internet
dans quelques instants on vous retrouve
prochainement pour d'autres idées merci
beaucoup d'être venu partager justement
ces différents rendez vous